Hey, everybody.
Great to be back in the studio.
We had the Fourth of July holiday over the
weekend and it's not it's not really feeling
like a great time to be proud about being
an American or living in the United States.
And it's only getting worse as restrictions
on where Americans are allowed to go around
the world continue to grow.
We talked.
I mean, listen, I said months ago that it's
likely that as other countries get corona
virus under control and we don't because of
our failed, incompetent leadership, we will
not be allowed to participate in the travel
that is now becoming commonplace in other
parts of the world.
And case in point, the United States is included
in a list of countries from which people cannot
travel to Europe, despite Europe being widely
re-opened, spoke to friends in France and
Belgium over the weekend.
And, you know, they're taking precautions,
masks on public transit.
But restaurants are open, things are happening.
People are traveling between European countries.
Americans are not allowed to go there.
It's getting even worse.
Now, the Mexican state of Sonora has closed
the border to the United States.
Specifically, their border is with the state
of Arizona ahead of the July 4th weekend.
The governor of Sonora saying that American
travelers are not going to be allowed to come
in.
There's too much of a risk with corona virus
being rampant in Arizona and in the United
States.
They don't want Americans on sand or in beaches.
July 4th is a peak tourism time for Americans
going over there.
Now, before we go even further, is anybody
else a little bit confused about going to
another country to celebrate our Independence
Day?
I mean, I guess conceptually, if you just
think about it as time off, then you go wherever.
There's no rule that says you have to stay
in the United States.
But it is interesting that in a state like
Arizona, which is not a particularly progressive
state, there would be so much desire on our
Independence Day to leave the country and
to go to Mexico.
I guess if you're under 21, it makes more
sense because you can drink in Mexico and
not in the United States legally anyway.
But there's something about that that's maybe
a little bit counterintuitive.
But in any case, in any case, Americans are
not allowed to cross the border from Arizona
into Sonora.
A reopening date has not yet been announced.
And it's just too dangerous.
Americans are a danger to Mexico.
Mexico having its own fair share of troubles
controlling Corona virus.
But Arizona, one of the global hot spots at
this point, never mind.
One of the American hot spots, the growth
rate of cases in Arizona, one of one of the
largest in the world.
And it does seem.
I mean, listen, I understand why they're doing
it.
I don't like that we can't travel to Europe.
I had a trip to Europe planned in June.
Obviously, it was canceled.
I was hoping that I could reschedule it to
August.
I haven't.
And it doesn't look like that's going to be
even remotely safe.
So I'm not going to do it.
So from a personal perspective, I don't like
it.
But you have to imagine that a lot of the
people going from Arizona to Mexico for the
Fourth of July during a pandemic are not going
to be what we would call our best to borrow
a term from Donald Trump.
It's probably the anti maskers, maybe anti
vaccines as well.
Conspiracy theorists, the so-called liberty
people may be birthers.
True, thirds of different persuasions, Trump
and gun people.
Q Anon's And of course, because of the virus,
probably some covered people as well, because
who else would really be doing for unnecessary
foreign travel right now is Dr. Anthony Fauci,
who recently said he would only get onto an
airplane in an emergency right now.
So the numbers in Arizona are horrifying,
98000 total cases probably by the end of today.
Arizona will be at hundred thousand total
cases, approaching 2000 deaths, very fast
growth rate, peak death.
No, so far in Arizona was just a few days
ago.
July 1st is the day on which Arizona has had
the most single day deaths.
And looking at case numbers, it would not
be shocking that they best that in the next
few days.
Sinora in Mexico, the state of Sonora, their
hospitals are filling up.
Their testing capacity is limited.
They can't afford a spike.
So they're saying, sorry, Americans, you can't
come here.
So parts of Mexico are now closed to Americans.
The Canadian border is closed except for essential
travel with mandatory quarantine can't fly
to Europe.
They wanted nationalism were sort of weirdly
getting this isolationist nationalism not
exactly by our choice, but happening as a
result of other countries instituting limitations
on Americans.
The optimistic, hopeful scenario right now,
I don't want to blow smoke anywhere, you know,
up, down, wherever it is you don't want to
smoke blown.
I don't want to blow it.
But the optimistic scenario right now is Biden
defeats Trump when he takes over in January.
We likely still have a huge mess.
Hopefully by then there's an early vaccine.
There's initial vaccine access by January.
I think up.
Mystic would be health care workers and some
of the most vulnerable.
And it will still probably be six months beyond
that of Biden focusing heavily on coronavirus
to really get things under control economically
and medically.
We're going to talk about the economic component
in a little bit.
And of course, a lot of this will depend on
Republican obstruction, which is why taking
control of the Senate in November, in addition
to removing Donald Trump, is so clearly important.
And because we're here for the full week this
week, no days off this week, later this week,
I'm going to revisit the topic of the Senate,
which I think is a really important one.